Chile's president Gabrielle borage tries
to console the mother of the latest
policeman killed in the line of duty
[Music]
son she sobs while three former Chilean
presidents watch from the front row of
the church
33 year old Danielle Palma was shot in
the head at Point Blank grange on
Wednesday the fourth policeman murdered
while on patrol in less than a month
enough enough of killing those who
guarantee our safety today there is a
child a wife and an institution that is
suffering
the latest killing has shaken a country
that until five years ago thought it was
immune to the type of violent crimes
that plagued many of Chile's neighbors
now security or the lack of it has
become a national priority
three policemen murdered in the last
Fortnight that's something that can't
happen in Chile it's never happened
before and it can't continue
following the latest victim's funeral
president boric signed a controversial
new law allowing police to use lethal
force on the presumption that they're in
danger
the situation we're facing has been
brewing for a long time and has multiple
causes it won't be easy to confront its
worst expression are the assassinations
we've had to lament these past weeks
Chile has seen an upsurge in drug
trafficking and illegal weapons but also
gangs and organized crime groups who've
entered Chile from Venezuela and
Colombia
in the last five years hundreds of
thousands of undocumented migrants have
entered this country including two
Venezuelans suspected of having killed
as policemen
rightly or wrongly more and more
Chileans are blaming some of them for
importing crime to this country here in
the capital some Mayors are even
demanding that the government declare a
state of emergency in their counties
where nearly 40 percent of crimes are
committed
starting Monday undocumented migrants
suspected of committing a crime will be
placed under preventive detention until
their identity and innocence can be
established another unprecedented step
to see a Newman Al Jazeera Santiago